hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer weiteren
episode von ebay fails die serie auf
youtube bei der ihr danach keine
gehirnzellen mehr haben werden wir
allerdings direkt mit dem ersten ebay
feld und zwar verkauft hier jemand einen
laptop und die person die den kaufen
will seht ihr ja schon schreibt ist sky
inklusive daraufhin antwortet der
verkäufer natürlich nicht was ist das
für eine saudumme frage warum schreibst
du es dann rein du mal ab was ist ein
maul ab als marvin werden seit dem
mittelalter tönerne kopf förmige halter
für teamspiele bezeichnet in deren
offenes manuel man dem kind sparen
steckte
ach damit allerdings noch nicht genug
meine damen und herren daraufhin
schreibt der potenzielle käufer dieses
laptops dann noch stirb du echsen mensch
und was ist bitte ein exotisch mensch
nicht gesund ziemlich abstoßend kommen
ja herr dick ist direkt zum zweiten
liebefeld und meine lieben freunde hier
verkauft jemand kopfhörer und die person
die diese kopfhörer haben möchte sagt
nicht irgendwie hey ich biete so und so
viel geld nein sie sagt hallo hätten sie
lust auf tausch gegen honig also ich
würde auch gern meine kopfhörer gegen
hole ich tauschen das hier ist der
nächste fehler und zwar verkauft die
eine person ein iphone 5 s die person
die das den kaufen möchte schreibt ist
das handy noch zu haben hätte interesse
und zwei fragezeichen daraufhin schreibt
der verkäufer ja und die antwort von den
potenziellen käufer ist keine lust mehr
wegen vier minuten ihr schreit ja das
ding noch zu haben ist und vier minuten
später antwortete die person und eine
minute später hat der typ dann keinen
bock mehr hat er in vier minuten wieder
bock hallo ich interessiere mich für den
bürostuhl wie intensiv wurde der benutzt
und von wem das ist die frage die an den
verkäufer eines bürostuhls gestellt
wurde der antwortete daraufhin nur von
mir nicht täglich der stunde sticker
drei jahre alt und in sehr gutem zustand
und dann schreibt der typ der da drin
kaufen möchte darf ich sie auch zusammen
mit dem stuhl bit nehmen
also freunde wenn ihr jetzt noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal sei dann kann
ja auch nicht weiter auf meinem kanal
wird gebildet es wird intellektuell
wissen vermittelt also warum seid ihr
noch kein abonnent klicken unter dem
video auf abonnieren ich warte ihn
seine fertig gut perfekt war da geht's
hallo ich würde gerne wissen warum
kostet den so ein großer hässlicher
schuh so viel geld danke mit
freundlichen grüßen ich kann mir
wirklich vorstellt das ist eine ernst
gemeinte frage war von beispielsweise
einem älteren ebay nutzer der eine ebay
anzeige gesehen hat von unter anderem
keine ahnung irgendwie einem komischen
sneaker ich meine die sehen ja immer
komischer aus das hier ist eine e mail
anfrage für einen babysitter
beziehungsweise eine kinderbetreuung und
eine person fragt darunter hallo darf
ich dich etwas fragen die begrüßte
daraufhin bekommt sie die antwort hallo
ja klar was denn und dann schreibt die
person wieder danke hast du lust mit
deinen füßen etwas geld zu machen
wer will denn mit kleinen füßen wie wie
kann da überhaupt mit seinen füßen gr
okay vielleicht wenn man fußballer ist
allerdings hängt weiter mit dem nächsten
die welt verändern zwar verkauft hier
jemand sein boot beziehungsweise wurde
es schon verkauft hat er da oben
geschrieben daraufhin bekommt er
allerdings dennoch die nachrichten hallo
ich bin unterwegs und das finde ich
nicht gut was soll das wenn morgen bei
ihnen also die person lässt nicht locker
und da auf den schreibt der verkäufer
des bootes okay sie können gerne kommen
dann mache ich ihnen einen kaffee aber
das boot ist leider nicht mehr da fahre
54 kilometer
das boot ist nicht mehr da
was ist falsch mit solchen menschen ich
hab mir den email-verkehr noch mal
angeschaut und leute
ich lese es euch einfach untereinander
von hier wird ein iphone 6 mit 16
gigabyte verkauft daraufhin schreibt ein
potenzieller käufer hallo und der
verkäufer antwortete daraufhin hallo der
käufer schreibt nicht der verkäufer
antwortet nee der käufer antwortet okay
dass meine damen und herren ist der
komplette chat verlauf
frag mich an der stelle wirklich gar
nichts mehr der nächste feld zeigt uns
einfach dass es auch leute gibt die
gerne viel geld ausgeben möchten und
zwar schreibt jemand hier noch daraufhin
schreibt der verkäufer heiler ist noch
da also das produkt was die personen
kaufen möchte ist noch vorhanden
daraufhin einfach die anderen wieder
bitte was ist der letzter preis
ich würde dir das hier erst mal
empfehlen zu kaufen miete 50 euro geht
ich komme abholung also er schreibt er
würde 50 euro bezahlen und würde das
ding auch abholen daraufhin schreibt der
typen 1 70 euro und jetzt antwortet der
typ so richtig wirtschaftlich denken
okay 75 euro warum noch 70 euro zahlen
wir noch fünf euro mehr zahlen kann
basic befehl alter da fragen wir auch
wieder anders die user fragt hier heil
15 plus versand als er fragt ob das
produkt 15 euro plus versand kostet
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer ja
genau sonst würde es sich nicht mehr
lohnen versand kostet fünf euro
daraufhin fragt dann der interessierte
ja genau oder nicht so und bekommt
daraufhin die antwort ja 15 euro plus
fünf euro versandt und dann meine damen
und herren lässt er seine mathis geht es
raus hängen dann muss ich 15 euro zahlen
ja 15 + 5 sind 15 dir würde ich dann das
hier empfehlen erstmals zu kaufen
weiter mit dem nächsten die werkstatt
felder und zwar würde ich mir hier am
liebsten meinen kopf zehn mal gegen
meine band und ich frage mich einfach
was das für eine unterhaltung ist er
schreibt 600 euro für alles lg normale
nachricht bekommt die antwort nein lg
und dann okay lg
das war
abonniert main kanal gern also jetzt
echt hammer content zu sehen klickt
unter dem video auf abonnieren oder eure
ärmel rutschen runter beim händewaschen
ex ging allerdings nicht auf ende des
heutigen videos sagen gekommen meine
damen und herren mensch da freut sie ja
wahrscheinlich gar keiner hier verkauft
jemand eine schwarze ikea modul küche er
daraufhin bekommt er die frage guten tag
kurze frage ist der rosafarbene brodkorb
auch zu verkaufen also ob der in dem
angebot mit drin ist daraufhin schreibt
er ganz normal nein und bekommt die
antwort ich will nicht wieder klatschen
durchlaufen aber er kommt nicht mehr
lange wenn ich jemanden hast bist du das
dumme ist
[Musik]
das
bei der nächste ebay der seine dummheit
wirklich nicht zu überbieten weil ich
mich zeigen euch erstmal hier schreibt
jemand hallo könnten sie sich einen
preis von 1900 euro vorstellen daraufhin
schreibt der verkäufer jahr könnte ich
aber nicht
warum
sein sohn an
in der tat bei mir ist die beerfelder
mit wieder so eine komische preisfrage
und zwar verkauft jemand einen samsung
galaxy s 5 smartphone der potenzielle
käufer oder der interessent an diesem
handy schreibt letzter preis bitte keine
ahnung was die alle mit ihrem englischen
haben aber da ja der verkäufer antwortet
auf jeden fall 80 daraufhin versucht der
andere typ noch zu handeln schreibt 50
fragezeichen daraufhin der verkäufer
wieder ich hab doch gesagt 80 ist der
letzte preis ok público
[Musik]
das auch für dich eine empfehlung doch
nur meine damen und herren ob wir zu
einem heber in die saiten einziger die
plattform ebay wirklich verstanden hat
der weiß worum es geht die arbeit und
für sich lohnt zu kämpfen und was er in
seinem leben erreichen wir um mein gott
ich kündige dass die kasse an als letzte
folge game of thrones apropos schaut ihr
game of thrones schreibt man die
kommentare weil ich glaube ich bin der
einzige der die serie überhaupt nicht
nice findet aber zurück zum ebay feld
und zwar schreibt der user namens amiri
hier hallo ich bin 50 euro wieso wollen
sie 50 euro
daraufhin schreibt amiri sei bitte nicht
böse
was ich habe nur ein preis gesagt amiri
du hast ebay wirklich verstanden anders
hätte mich das häufig videos allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch meine reaktion immer wieder auf
einige male stand fans gefallen hatte
lassen unbedingt einen daumen hoch hier
unter dem video dar und klickt auf
abonnieren unter dem video weil ich
sonst euren fortnight account löschen
wenn ihr bock auf dieses niveau die hier
hat oder beispielsweise auch auf diesen
schwarzen neopren rodeo oder
beispielsweise auf dieses weißes t-shirt
auf dem jupiter drauf steht oder ob
dieses t shirt was auch ein smiley
hälfte hälfte drauf hat oder wenn die
bock auf dieses pop socket ihr habt dann
kann ich euch leider nicht weiterhelfen
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr am
ersten sechs und 15 uhr im lokal
shopping de vorbeischauen würde denn
dann lautstark meine neue kollektion wir
werden von jedem verkauften produkt von
dem gewinn einen euro spenden an die
stiftung gegen rassismus und hoffen
damit ein zeichen setzen zu können dass
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr euch
den termin im kalender markiert dann
vielleicht im shop vorbeischaut und
jetzt
[Musik]